hi everyone i'm chris
elpy the ohsu university librarian and
one of your faculty in the department of
medical informatics and clinical
epidemiology
i'm excited to offer you today this
video on how to go to the library
virtually and efficiently from off
campus on your own device
the video is a bit long but i hope that
you'll come to see by the end of it that
we are your learning care and discovery
partner
anytime and anywhere and that
particularly extends now to making sure
that you all have access to what you
need in the virtual environment
so this video is going to focus on your
24 7 access to online resources
and some of the things that we in the
library can help you with through
consultations
in terms of literature and data
discovery evaluation and organization
but please know that even though it's
not covered in this video
the library also offers professional
development workshops
and guidance through programs like the
biodata club again done in collaboration
with
dmice faculty so
the contact information for us for today
is here on this slide
and this slide will again appear at the
end of the video there will also be
access to the slide deck for
those of you whom a long video is just
not
something you want to engage please
contact us or make an appointment if you
have any questions
or if you'd like to recommend something
for purchase
so let's start with efficient access to
articles and how you can cite them in
your coursework or your research
publications
to work efficiently from off campus on
your own device
it is best to start with the library's
website
this starting with the library website
link will enable you to be
authenticated through ohsu to all of the
resources that we license
so on the library homepage there is both
the opportunity to search our
collections
and to request assistance kind of the
links to all of those specific addresses
we provided on the previous slide
and the address is just www.ohsu.edu
forward slash library or google or
search
ohsu library so when you search at the
library's website on the homepage there
will be this list of our most popular
resources
by the end of the video you'll see that
this is just the beginning
of the many resources you have available
but you want to start there because
those links
have built into them something that will
prompt you for your ohsu credentials to
authenticate
once you log in with your issue user id
and password
you will be prompted to authenticate
with duo
so let's focus on pubmed first although
pubmed is free and you can go to it
without following all of these ohsu
steps if you want to be able to access
the full text of articles once you've
found them in pubmed
you'll need to have either started at
the ohsu
pubmed link or you would be logged into
an ncbi account through pubmed that is
connected to ohsu
and on the forthcoming slides we'll look
at how to do that
before we go into the benefits of an
ncbi account which i've listed here on
the right hand side
in terms of being able to create alerts
to save search strategies
to save collections of citations and to
get that
full-text article that ohsu subscribes
to that isn't free
i did want to point out two other things
on the pubmed homepage that you may or
may not be familiar with
first of all for us in informatics is
this e-utilities function
when we go to download references you'll
see that there are a lot of limitations
on the number and
fields available to us but if we want to
download larger quantities and different
information
the e-utilities api is very useful for
that
and then here in the search example i've
shown you the search is entirely
generated with
text words interprofessional observation
and students and clinical placements
but if you're doing more advanced
searching and wanting to use medical
subject headings
the bolded area there for explore the
mesh database is another tool that will
be useful
for you so if you already have an ncbi
account you would just click on login
in the top right corner if you don't
have an account
you'll be able to set one up but let's
go through what this looks like once you
are engaged in pubmed so
i've just run that search on the home
page and i want to save this search
and i also want to get updates on it so
that i don't have to
pay attention to when new papers come
out i'll just get an email
so once i've run the search the option
to create alert click
shows up under the search box and when i
click on that
i'll get the option to save the search
and down at the bottom it says would you
like email
updates of new search results if you say
yes you'll get a whole list of
other options for how frequently you
want the results what format you want
the results in
etc i actually set mine to get email
updates every day not because i think
that there's going to be a new paper on
this topic every day
but because i want to be notified as
soon as that paper is available
another useful feature in pubmed that
does require an
ncbi account is the ability to save to
collections
and i think this is particularly
important for folks who get
interrupted when they're reviewing their
citations pubmed does not stay
does not leave your search results
available forever and so
if you know you're likely to get
interrupted you're sharing a computer
one of the things you can do is take
your search results and save them to a
collection
so that you can review them later
especially if you've already gone
through a large result set and
identified
several that are relevant and you don't
want to lose track of them
so once you've checked off what you need
if you click on send to
one of the options will be collections
again if you don't have an account yet
it'll prompt you to create an account at
that time
if you want to just capture the
citations to cite them
in your work or use them and to put them
into a citation management software
program
you can either use the send to citation
manager which takes
up to 200 citations in the pubmed nbib
format or if you need more than 200 or a
different format
go ahead and go over to the save button
and you'll be able to choose the pubmed
format which produces a
txt file in a tagged format that you can
import into any program
or another option as we mentioned is to
use the e-utilities
api but let's say
right now you're just interested in
reading a few papers and maybe citing
one or two of those when you're looking
at your search results on the left hand
side of each citation you'll see a
little link that says cite
so when you click on site you'll get the
citation for that single article
in one of the formats and i've shown
this here on the right
the ama apa modern language association
or the nlm format
and usually the ama format in vancouver
are very similar
likewise the nlm format in vancouver are
very similar
but the nlm format is going to put the
pubmed id
and the pubmed central url both at the
end of your citation which you
wouldn't need for citing in the
vancouver style normally
if you want to actually read the the
article then go ahead and click on the
title
of the article this is going to take you
to the screen with the abstract where
you can see the full text links
and so here's an example of that because
we started at the pubmed
url for the ohsu library you can see on
the right hand side
under the publishers graphic link there
is the find it
at ohsu library link and this will give
you the most direct full text
access and it won't require you to be on
the ohsu network or on an ohsu computer
you can just do this on your personal
computer when you click on find it at
ohsu library it will ask you to
authenticate
so if you've started though not at the
ohsu
library pubmed link and you've done your
search and you found
interesting materials but you want to
get full text there is one way to go
ahead and do that without starting over
and that is to log into your ncbi
account
and have your ncbi account set up with
pubmed preferences that's that identify
that you're with oregon health and
sciences university
so once you've got your account created
and you go to the account settings
at the very bottom of that page there's
a place that says ncbi
site preferences i know this is a lot of
steps i've put a lot of detail on all of
these slides
once you're on the ncbi site preferences
page there's a section for pubmed
preferences
and then a section there for outside
tool
which i've shown here and you choose
oregon health and sciences university
this is also helpful for those of you
who have multiple institutional
affiliations
so you could also choose the outside
tool for your other institution
and be able to go back and forth between
having access to multiple institutions
you can do something similar to access
full text from google scholar and since
a lot of our work in informatics also
includes computer science and other
areas that are perhaps not as well
covered by pubmed i want to be sure to
show you this
option so if you've done a search in
google scholar
and you could also use an ohsu library
specific address for google scholar but
we're going to assume that you haven't
go ahead and click on the hamburger on
the left of google scholar there to
access your settings
and login to google
when you're on the google scholar screen
then you see there's
settings on the left hand side menu and
there's two that we want to call your
attention to
one is on the search results tab there's
an option to change the bibliography
manager option
so for those of you who use a reference
manager
or by the end of this video you might be
convinced to use a reference manager
you can actually tell google scholar to
show you
that link so that you can import your
google citations
easily into those reference managers and
that's what's shown on the top right of
this slide
that you can choose to import your
citations into bib text or endnote
which can be used by any of the
reference management programs
but to get the access to the full text
you want to go to the setting for
library links which is shown on the
bottom right
and then you can search on oregon health
and science university and select that
and save your settings and on the next
slide here
you can see that now when you search
google scholar
that find it at ohsu library shows up on
the right hand side menu
and you can get the most direct full
text access there
and then when you click on that you're
going to come to the full text of the
article where you can click on the pdf
to get it through the ohsu library's
subscription
if the library doesn't own the article
you're looking for in digital format
instead of going directly to the article
you're going to go to this screen
and you'll see an option to request it
via the get it for me service
and that is our online full text
delivery of things not owned by the
library
it's no cost to you it will cover
online journals print materials that
need to be scanned
get it for me also does do physical
loading of books
and for those of you who are distance
students we will mail books to you with
a postage paid return mailer
get it for me also is what drives some
of our purchasing so
if you need a certain journal and you're
requesting it through get it for me
we learn what your needs are and then we
consider that journal for future
purchase
so i've already alluded to the fact that
you might want to be using a reference
manager for your work
and here's just a little bit more
information about that we have three
slides on this
so if you've been downloading existing
pdfs and you have a folder or kind of a
desktop full of them
but you want to actually get them into a
nice list of references so you're able
to cite them
all of the reference managers shown here
can actually just
ingest your pdfs and assuming
they're relatively recent or
decent quality scans they will be able
to recognize the citation
and therefore you kind of already get
the list of references for them
once you have one of these programs set
up if you're citing your work in an
article that uses one style versus
another
and you need to switch quickly the
programs can actually
make that transition for you easily and
we'll show that on the next slide
so the three that people usually ask us
about our endnote
mendeley and zotero and you can see here
a comparison chart
the ohsu library provides endnote but we
also will help you with free ones like
mendeley and zotero
so here's an example of what this looks
like
um so you can go from the vancouver
style at the top
to the apa style at the bottom
very simply using the citation manager
and on the right i just have a quick
note of for those of you who have always
wondered
why why is there something called the
vancouver style
um that was where the international
committee of medical journal editors met
when they came up with this idea that we
needed to be
standardized in our citation if you're
citing things
other than paper such as conference
proceedings software
patents those formats can be covered
well for you
if you need to know more inciting
medicine which is a free resource online
but all the citation manager programs
will also have
ways for you to enter references for
things manually and
will let you choose what type of thing
you're entering
it is helpful when you're entering if
you don't already have a folder full of
full text that pdfs that you're
ingesting into your citation manager and
you are bringing in just references
say from pubmed or google scholar the
programs can also help you
find the full text for those more easily
so you don't have to
import and tie each one together you
just need to set up your
reference manager with these addresses
so that
the program can authenticate and find
what ohsu has to offer
and here's an example of what it looks
like on the endnote guide
and what addresses you should use and
the setup is very similar and other
products
so now that we've been through a lot of
detail about getting access to full text
and citing articles
let's wrap up this video with three
types of knowledge resources that aren't
really discoverable in
pubmed or google scholar but might be
helpful to your work here in dmice
so these are learning materials intended
to get you kind of from your first year
to your final project whatever that
might be
so we'll start with textbooks and course
reserves
and also the idea of searching our
libraries catalog for
books in case your instructor has not
put it on course reserve or let us know
that it's a textbook
we'll talk about resources for clinical
information and then we'll talk about
digital collections where
work by existing and past dmi students
is available to you for consultation
so here we'll start with searching the
library's catalog
we've searched for dr hirsch and
informatics
and we can the default here on the left
hand side
is typically relevance but i've put it
to date newest
and on the left hand side you see you
can also refine the results so if you
really don't want print books and you
only want ebooks or only materials from
a certain time you can do that
i've focused this search just on
materials at ohsu but we have
partnerships
with many other libraries including the
university of washington the university
of oregon and oregon state university
with large collections
so that little pull down there by ohsu
can give you access to books from many
other institutions
again free from get it for me
so the first book here um dr hirsch has
a chapter in it and the book is on
reserve
physical course reserve in the library
but if you look down to the third book
we have dr hirsch's new ebook on
information retrieval the fourth edition
so if you click on available online
there
you will get prompted for the library's
remote access login
you use your credentials authenticate
with duo as we've already discussed
and then you're going to come to this
particular publishers page for the book
i have to tell you ebook options are the
most confusing thing
i can't possibly show you all of them
they vary by publisher from
unlimited download by unlimited users
like this book
to ones where you can view only by a
single user at a time
and so i would really encourage you to
look at the limits and options on each
book as you
encounter it so that you can decide what
you need
from it and figure out what your best
approach will be
this particular book lets you download
the entire book in pdf
or an epub which can be used by your
reader devices
or you can go for the pdf of a
particular chapter that you need
those most limited books some of them
the only way to save
content from them is to print or save
selected pages or chapters to pdf
and some of them may limit the number of
pages in a session
or the number of pages total that we can
use from a book and that's why i say
please do explore the options on the
interface for the particular book that
you're looking at
in addition to the library catalog with
the e-books as i've just mentioned we
also have
a great number of online databases and
resources
well beyond that selection of popular
resources on the homepage we showed you
earlier in the video
these are helpful when you're looking
for information but you're not
having a particular citation in mind and
these will cover both bibliographic
citations and abstracts such as pubmed
that we already looked at or scopus
which is a multi-disciplinary citation
and abstract database
but also databases with facts or
clinical summaries such as drug
information and lexicomp or micromedics
and clinical summaries in dynamed plus
and
up to date and because we get a lot of
questions about dynamed plus and up to
date i will show you
a quick comparison of what those look
like in terms of
answering clinical questions or giving
you background on a clinical problem
for those of you who are may not be as
familiar with clinical resources
so here i think we're all under stress
these days so i'm sharing you the
entries for attention type headaches or
stress headaches
you can see on the left dynamed has the
management overview here and and links
to levels of evidence for various
treatments
and on the right you have up-to-date
similar topic outline
referencing journal articles and if you
click on the numbers you'll be
taken down to the end of the list to see
the actual references
so the last category of resources i
wanted to share with you is actually how
you learn from your fellows
gmy student research projects especially
if you're looking for role models for
your own capstone or thesis work
so you can visit the library's digital
collections
at this address and then there's
actually a separate category
highlighting biomedical informatics if
you click on biomedical informatics here
then you will see the theses and
capstones and dissertations that have
been deposited
and you can search by keywords in this
group
or you can simply search simply sort
by relevance or date uploaded to see
the most recent items attached to this
and
things have changed over time in their
structure so if you're looking at how to
set up
a capstone or set up a thesis you
definitely want to look at
more recent ones rather than older ones
because things have changed
so here we have searched by we have
sorted by date uploaded
and then here is the first entrance in
that
it's a dissertation and we click on
download the file
and we get the pdf of this particular
piece of d mice
scholarship so i hope you've enjoyed
this whirlwind
tour of how to get the most convenient
full-text
access and site things in your work i
want to leave you with
this connect connect to us slide contact
us connect to us and
all of it's good and then for those of
you who may visit us in portland
i want to offer this final slide if you
do visit portland we really look forward
to meeting you in person
in the bc building the library is on the
second
and third and fourth floors um
dmice is on the fourth and fifth floors
we have a 24
7 space in the book for all members we
have networked computers
special workstations you can check out
emerging technologies
meet in technology equipped spaces and
even do mundane things like
printing and scanning so thank you very
much for your patience and attention to
this video
i hope that you've learned something
that will help you succeed in your work
in d mice
and i look forward to meeting you in the
future thank you